aquí tengo las preguntas de geometría
del examen estandarizado de california
vamos a resolver cada una de ellas
empecemos con esta la número uno déjame
leerla dice cuál de las siguientes
opciones describe de la mejor manera el
razonamiento deductivo a mí no me gustan
mucho estas preguntas en las cuales nos
preguntan por definiciones en
matemáticas pero ni modo aquí está y
vamos a resolverla entonces nos
preguntan acerca de el razonamiento
deductivo del razonamiento deductivo y
la definición de razonamiento deductivo
bueno en vez de dar una definición
déjame explicarte de qué se trata y
luego vemos si se parece a algo de lo
que está aquí el razonamiento deductivo
básicamente consiste en tomar algunos
enunciados como ciertos y a partir de
ellos sacar algunas conclusiones que
sabemos que tienen que ser verdaderas
por ejemplo déjame poner por aquí este
enunciado todos los niños son altos
todos los niños son altos
los niños son altos son altos
y este otro enunciado de acá juan es un
niño juan es un niño un niño entonces
suponiendo que estas dos oraciones son
verdaderas podemos concluir una tercera
oración como todos los niños son altos y
juan es un niño entonces juan es alto
juan juan es alto
alto sale entonces la idea fue tenemos
algunas oraciones o algunos enunciados
que tomamos como ciertos y a partir de
ellos le encontramos otra cosa más
encontramos otro otro cierto enunciado
bueno a este tipo de razonamiento se le
conoce como razonamiento deductivo
deductivo y hay otras formas de razonar
por ejemplo también existe el
razonamiento inductivo ahorita no me voy
a meter con un ejemplo porque pues
estamos en deductivo y no quiero que nos
confundamos demasiado pero en el
razonamiento inductivo de lo que se
trata es de encontrar algunos patrones a
partir de ciertas observaciones que
hacemos y a partir de ahí pues proponer
algunas generalizaciones pero bueno el
razonamiento inductivo no es lo que
queremos ahorita queremos razonamiento
deductivo vamos a ver si encontramos la
definición en el lenguaje que utilizan
ahí en california entonces la opción a
dice usar la lógica para obtener
conclusiones basándose en hechos
aceptados pues si eso suena bastante
bien verdad eso suena exactamente a lo
que hicimos aquí usamos la lógica
basándonos en hechos aceptados para
tener algunas conclusiones entonces
hasta ahorita yo me iría por la a pero
vamos a leer las demás para ver si
algunas se parecen y así se parece más
pues entonces ve aceptar el significado
de un término sin definir que eso está
como muy raro de hecho no creo que nada
sea aceptar el significado de un término
definido no sé cómo alguien podría hacer
eso entonces no está suena que no es la
cee definir términos matemáticos para
que correspondan con objetos físicos no
o no tampoco se parece a lo que
platicamos aquí al lado a ver la de
inferir una verdad general a partir de
examinar un cierto número de ejemplos
específicos bueno esto sí se parece a
una cosa que platicamos pero se parece
mucho más a razonamiento inductivo no a
razonamiento deductivo entonces yo me
iría por la opción a vale entonces la
opción la opción
ok vamos con la siguiente pregunta
afortunadamente aquí ya pegué todas
estas preguntas porque en geometría
sería muy latosos ponerme a hacer todos
los dibujos pero bueno voy a leer en el
siguiente diagrama el ángulo 1 es
congruente con a este símbolo este
símbolo se llama congruente con dejarlo
a punto por acá es como un igual con una
barrita así y chueca arriba entonces es
es congruente
y cuando nos dicen que dos ángulos son
congruentes básicamente se refieren a
que esos dos ángulos tienen la misma
medida nos están diciendo que el ángulo
1 tiene la misma medida que el ángulo 4
déjame marcarlo por acá entonces este de
aquí tiene la misma medida que este de
acá y la diferencia entre ser
congruentes y ser iguales es que pues
dos ángulos pueden tener la misma medida
pero pueden ser ángulos distintos en el
sentido de que están en diferentes
lugares o están hechos por distintas
rectas en fin cuando nos dicen que son
congruentes únicamente nos importa la
medida vale bueno vamos a seguir leyendo
a ver qué nos dicen nos preguntan cuál
de las siguientes conclusiones no tiene
que ser forzosamente cierta ok entonces
a ángulo 3 y ángulo cuatro son ángulos
suplementarios vamos a acordarnos que
son que quiere decir que dos ángulos
sean suplementarios aquí con el ángulo
tres y cuatro eso nos está diciendo que
el ángulo 3
más el ángulo 4 el ángulo 4 las medidas
suman 180 grados tal entonces esto de
aquí es que los ángulos sean
suplementarios
adiós
suplementarios muy bien bueno pues vamos
a ver si eso siempre puede ser cierto
entonces el ángulo 3 es suplementario
con el 4 de hecho son ángulos opuestos
por este vértice y entonces tienen que
ser congruentes entre sí el ángulo 13 es
congruente al 4 a lo mejor digo que son
iguales a lo mejor se me pasa en vez de
decir congruentes va bueno pero como son
opuestos por el vértice son ángulos
congruentes de hecho puedes jugar para
ver que eso siempre pasa no importa como
muevas de esta línea siempre van a tener
la misma media medida pero entonces no
tendrían por qué ser suplementarios por
ejemplo si el ángulo 4 éste mide 95
grados el 3 también y no suman 180 si
éste fuera de 100 grados el de acá
también entonces no sumarían 180 sino
200 o si fuera 30 y 30 pues sumarían 60
entonces hay muchísimos casos que se me
ocurren en los cuales la suma de estos
dos ángulos no es 180 grados y por lo
tanto suena muchísimo a que la opción a
es la que no siempre es forzosamente
cierta o sea si es cierta cuando el 3 y
el 4 los dos miden 90 grados porque son
iguales verdad pero en otros casos no
entonces suena aquí
no tiene que ser forzosamente cierta
pero vamos a leer las demás a ver qué
pasa a ver ve la línea l es paralela a
la línea m l es paralela a m
pues eso sí es cierto porque a ver
pensemos tantito si la línea l fuera
paralela a la m entonces tendríamos
algunas igualdad desde ángulos verdad
que el ángulo 1 sería congruente al
ángulo 3 cuando algunas congruencias el
ángulo 1 sería igual al ángulo 3 este
pero aquí tenemos que el ángulo 1 es
igual al ángulo 3 porque nos dicen nos
dicen acá arriba que el ángulo 1 es
igual al 4 y ya vimos que el 4 es
opuesto al vértice al 3
entonces el 1 el 1 es igual al 3 y
entonces estas dos rectas son paralelas
entonces la b siempre es cierta esto de
aquí siempre sucede vale la c la se nos
dice el ángulo 1 es congruente al ángulo
3 bueno pues ya eso es justo lo que
dijimos ahorita verdad el ángulo 4 es
congruente al ángulo 1 el 4 es
congruente al 3 entonces el 1 es
congruente al 3 los 3 tienen la misma
medida y ahora vayamos con la opción de
el ángulo 2 es congruente al ángulo 3
pues a ver el ángulo 2 está aquí este
ángulo es opuesto al vértice al 1
entonces estos dos ángulos de aquí son
congruentes y entonces ya los cuatro son
ángulos congruentes y pues claro que el
2 queda queda congruente al 3 social 2
es congruente alumno del 1 es congruente
al 3 y entonces el ángulo 2 es
congruente al ángulo 3
entonces b c y d siempre son ciertas la
única que no no tiene que ser
forzosamente cierta es la opción a
entonces vamos a elegir aquí la opción a
muy bien vamos a pasar al problema
número 3 problema número 3 considera los
siguientes argumentos 1 cualquier
múltiplo de 4 spark 376 es múltiplo de 4
entonces 376 es par 376 ok 2 un número
puede ser escrito como un decimal que se
repite si es racional y no puede
describirse como un decimal que se
repite entonces pi no es racional ok
vamos a ver que nos preguntan cuál o
cuáles de existir usa o usan el
razonamiento deductivo o sea cuáles de
éstas
bueno pues a ver la primera la primera
nos dice cualquier múltiplo de 4 spark
376 es múltiplo de 4 entonces 376 es par
pues si esto es clarísimo verdad esto es
totalmente usar el razonamiento
deductivo tenemos esta oración como
cierta esta oración como cierta y a
partir de estas dos estamos concluyendo
correctamente
esta tercera de acá entonces la primera
definitivamente utiliza razonamiento
deductivo correcto bueno a ver la número
dos un número puede ser escrito como un
decimal que se repite si es racional ok
entonces déjame escribirlo para no
hacernos bolas si es racional lo voy a
poner aquí muy racional
relacional entonces se puede escribir
como un decimal que se repite entonces
lo voy a poner esto quiere decir que
este decimal que se repite como un
decimal
que se repite qué
repite a lo que se refiere esto de un
decimal que se repite es por ejemplo el
punto 33 333 qué es un tercio
básicamente es eso pero bueno nos dicen
que si algo es racional
entonces se puede escribir como un
decimal que se repite pero ojo no nos
dicen lo contrario no nos dicen que si
se puede escribir como un decimal que se
repite entonces es racional bueno vamos
a ver qué más dice dice pi no puede
describirse como un decimal que se
repite o sea pi no está acá pi pi no
está acá vale ese es una segunda oración
que nos dicen y la conclusión que
intentan obtener es entonces pino
irracional bueno pues vamos a ver si si
esto es suficiente o sea si pino está
aquí abajo y puede estar aquí arriba
bueno pues si fuera racional entonces la
primera oración nos dice que sería un
decimal que se repite pero la segunda
nos dice que pi no se puede escribir
como un decimal que se repite entonces
pi no puede ser racional y eso es justo
lo que concluye en verdad entonces pi no
es racional
entonces si esta de aquí abajo también
es razonamiento deductivo válido
entonces la respuesta sería
si tanto uno como dos tienen
razonamiento deductivo válido muy bien
vamos a dejarle hasta aquí le voy a
dejar aquí en el problema 3 en los
siguientes vídeos vamos a resolver más
problemas